Here's my solution. I have to define the start state given a set of people that are on the here side.
I have to define the here side and just make sure that we throw in the flashlight there.
Then on the other side there's nobody.
Lowestcostsearch--starting from the start state, we've already defined the successor function.
I'm defining a new function to test for a goal.
We already defined the cost function.
The new function to test for the goal is right here.
It says if not here--in other words, if there's nothing here, if there's nobody here at all,
it's the empty set, or if here is only the set of the flashlight.
That normally wouldn't happen, but I guess it could happen
if the initial problem was there's no people and just a flashlight.
Then you've got a solution with doing nothing at all.
I just wanted to make sure I covered that trivial case.